we're very worried about everyone who
was in Paris at the time because we
couldn't confirm who was safe and who
was it and then we learned that one of
Thomas's friend's was shot trying to
protect his wife I think I was a bit I
was very very worried that being in
public and actually being face to face
with people is gonna like some
confrontation is gonna happen but a
hundred percent of the other responses
were very very positive we had people
get emotional or cry and cry we had
people coming like to hug us and tell us
that like applaud us for what we were
doing and even kids like running at us
and giving us hugs it was let me
describe it is the most human thing
we've ever who ever lived like the
amount of love and peacefulness and just
positivity in the in the metro station
that morning was just on peril